how's it going bros my name is Peter Pan
before this video begins I have an
important announcement
PewDiePie legend of the brofist it's
finally coming out on Steam
finally you bros can play this on your
computers but even better grab your bro
because co-op is gonna be available in
this game it's coming out December 10th
so you know what you're gonna do during
Christmas so don't miss that and enjoy
the video how does the golden browse my
neighbor's welcome basket to the puddin
pie channel it's scaring me how do I do
the hat ok what is happening how long
okay
alright do you want to make out oh here
we go
if you want to rub my belly they raise
your hand yeah that's right you're like
this baby the [ __ ] is this guy yeah make
finding it hard to kiss keep my eyes
open
I'm not sleepy man I'm fine hey man all
right high five high five man yeah yeah
high five yeah yeah keep on it you want
tea party mate I can have a tea party in
your ass [ __ ]
give me that ass put your ass and riding
it on the street yeah that's right baby
yeah that's that's the spot baby kill me
I can't feel my legs so I killed me
please you like my teeth mate
they like my smile Jesus Christ you want
a some people do I had some beatbox
brick and break it down to me now girl
now Oh
oh [ __ ] right there all that but it all
bet it they are oh oh oh hell that day
oh yeah oh yeah we're all for fun right
there ah yeah look at him eyebrows man
yeah working oh let me guess your boobs
ha ha ha ha like this yeah you like this
the a come on come on you like
hey hey you're done
you wanna make out yeah y'all cowards
don't even smoke crack what so wait
they're yo cowards don't even smoke
crack
hey don't you don't even smoke crack
I've been alone a minute I thought I
tried it out I'm just going in with it I
get to go to prison [ __ ] you up [ __ ]
[ __ ] you up me you want that you going
you're going do you want dad tonight
alright hi everybody Hey hi-yah ah ah ah
ah sorry
oh nice to meet here my name is karai
this attack hi
Oh
share what the [ __ ] let me down ah yeah
awesome
yeah no tell me more please tell me more
about your daily exercise no really I do
care a lot about your diet please tell
me everything
come on yeah that's right yeah yeah tell
me more tell me more [ __ ] tell
me one more thing [ __ ] Oh
[ __ ]
when haters come I do this ah begun yes
Oh
do a little dance make a little love get
down tonight
get down I can't
hey no I'm I swear I'm I'm pissed too
much plastic surgery and Botox oh oh oh
my name is Inga Inga I'm from see then
hey hi I didn't know anyone want some
Swedish meatballs all right I think I
[ __ ] around enough with this
I love face Rick leave it like if you
want more it's a lot of fun you [ __ ]
around with thank you boys for watching
and as always stay awesome breasts open
your [ __ ] eyes there we go